las vegas prepares for sunday's game in
california and l.a another raider
actually back on the nfl's covet list
sports director chris matthews joins us
with more on the
raiders lineman trent brown and his
health challenges well i'll tell you
what brian certainly is just six days
ago after being removed off the nfl's
coveted list brown
is now back on the league's reserve
coveted list so he's out for this
sunday's game
here's what we know right now he's back
on the list still experiencing
complications from the virus
to what extent the writers aren't saying
now we wonder six days ago he was taken
off the list
could there be a sense of false security
with a false negative test result we
hear a lot about the
false positive what about the false
negative gruden telling us wednesday
that brown was back at the facility
so now they've got to do contact tracing
again find out who is in contact with
brown at that facility and
could this affect other raiders as they
prepare for the chargers game
this sunday lots of questions as the
raiders deal with this virus certainly
not the only team with the bug
but it has had an impact on this team
for sure as they try to get ready for
another game
a very important afc matchup against the
high-powered chargers
another big afc game obviously
big one last week these afc games count
up at the end it's a division game so it
makes it extra important for us uh
good good young quarterbacks playing at
a high level they got some really good
skills
skilled players on the outside to get
the ball too and they ran the ball i
think last week for 208 yards against
denver so uh
big challenge explosive offense they're
up there in all the categories
as far as total offense and all those
things so they're doing a good job it's
another big challenge for us
you'll hear who's going to be back on
offense this week another weapon for the
raiders as they prepare for los angeles
so we'll continue to keep you posted
on brown's condition and will it affect
other players or not as they get ready
for sunday's game of course the raiders
brian
balancing that offense and defense as
they get ready for that big team
on sunday